hello grammarians welcome to irregular
plurals part 4 the mutant plurals
yes friends these words have mutant
superpowers
in that they can transform
weirdly and obnoxiously not obeying any
other rules of english pluralization but
here's the cool thing there are only
seven words that behave this way what
way i'll explain by writing all of them
down the words are
foot
woman
man
tooth
goose
mouse
laos
looks pretty straightforward right uh
the thing about these words is that none
of them take s as a plural so the plural
of foot is not foots the plural of woman
is not woman's the plural of tooth is
not tooths
the reason these are called mutant
plurals is because the vowel sound the
oo or the uh or the a or the oo or the
oo or the ow or the ow turns into a
different sound turns into a different
vowel sound
so the plural of foot is not foot
but feet
the plural of woman is not woman's but
women
the plural of man is not man's
but men
the plural of tooth is not tooths
but teeth
the plural of goose is not gooses
but geese
the plural of mouse is not mouses
but mice
and the plural of laos
is not louses
but lice
you can see that mouse and laos actually
change their end spelling as well to
from s e to c even though it's the same
sound laos
lice
for whatever reason just from some quirk
of our spelling history not only do we
change the vowels used here we also
change the consonants you see
why is this the case i'm so glad you
asked i'm going to save that for another
video in the meantime just these seven
words one two three
four five six
seven are the only words in english that
behave this way so you're in luck this
is a handful of words to memorize and
provided you're not borrowing anyone
else's hats
ideally you won't have to worry about
lice very often
that's my hope you can learn anything
david out